-Whenever Donald Trump
holds a press conference,
his rambling, nonsensical
answers raise more questions
than the answers, so we decide
to hold another one,
right here, right now.
That's right.
Donald Trump
and the "Late Night" press corps
are here in our studio
and ready to go.
And without any further ado,
it's time for the "Late Nigh
White House Press Conference."
♪♪♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes, yes, Mr. President,
Mr. President.
Mr. President, Mr. President
yes, thank you.
Seth Meyers,
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
Mr. President, I'm dying to ask.
What's your least favorite thing
you have to do as president?
-Deal with foreign people.
[ Laughter ]
-Mr. President, what would b
on your son Eric's chair
if you started yelling at him?
-You'd have a puddle.
[ Laughter ]
-What's the best part of working
with Vice President Mike Pence
-His ass.
[ Laughter ]
-His ass?
-That whole thing is beautiful
[ Laughter and applause ]
-How many women do you hav
in your cabinet?
-We're trying to
get it down to one.
We have it down to two.
We think we can get it
down to one.
-I heard you called
Julia Louis-Dreyfus
after the series finale
of "Veep."
What did you tell her?
-I said, "Elaine, it's over.
[ Laughter ]
-Under your proposed
healthcare plan,
what happens if you have
a pre-existing condition?
-You just sit
and you just die with it.
[ Laughter ]
-Very honest.
Describe Ricki Lake
in eight words.
-One of the great lakes
of the world.
[ Laughter ]
-I know you know your olde
daughter is named Ivanka,
but what's your younger
daughter's name?
-It's a name I know very well.
-If you know it very well,
what is it then?
-Wait a minute, I have to deal
with China.
Forget about this stuff.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
I see what you did there.
What'd you think about Abraham
Lincoln's Gettysburg Address
-It wasn't one of
his better speeches.
He got no standing ovations.
-I know you're currently married
to your third wife, Melania,
but how old do you think
your next wife is right now?
-4 or 5.
[ Laughter ]
-Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelos
seem to be working togethe
a lot lately.
What's going on with those two
-I'll tell you,
they might be screwing.
[ Laughter ]
-How much skin do you have
on your body?
-216 acres.
[ Laughter ]
-What are your nicknames
for your sons, Don Jr. and Eric?
-Oil and Gas.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you say to your staff
after you eat
a bunch of McDonald's?
-You don't want to be
in this room very long
because you won't last.
[ Laughter ]
-What did you do
when the White House chef
prepared kale salad with quinoa?
-I fired his ass so fast.
[ Laughter ]
-We're almost out of time,
so I'd like to finish with
the question I always ask --
how's your penis?
-Getting worse and worse
every year.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Follow-up question --
how's your penis?
-It's a little crooked.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a little --
It's a little crooked?
Come on, be honest.
-Curving like hell.
-All right.
[ Laughter ]
Looks like we're out of time